hello everybody hope they are good
Bitcoin has been very volatile in the
last few days and it's been pretty much
because of this week over here we've
been talking about this target since
Tuesday okay on Tuesday we were around
here and we were talking about the idea
that if it was possible that Bitcoin
could go back to 48k to fill this week
and the truth is that since that video
that's pretty much everything that
Bitcoin has been doing okay it's been
pushing price up towards this week I
also was in through through the week and
I told you that 50% of the week you
could place a small size sell order okay
a short order uh with a small size
because it's possible that Bitcoin could
have just gone ex St away to the 100% of
the week but at the 50% of the week is
likely to see rejections especially when
you see a move like this okay that is
basically
overextended now from that level the 50%
of the week at 48,000 we saw a drop in
Bitcoin of exactly uh
$1,200 okay that was a nice sculp and
then on Friday I was telling you hey
guys be careful because if we see
Bitcoin pushing price up again to the
50% of the week and it consolidates
around there then it's likely that we
see one more pushup higher okay aiming
for the 100% of the week and that's what
has happened a few hours ago check out
this Candlestick here okay look at that
Spike that's a spike targeting the 100%
of the week now it didn't there all the
way we missed by
$150 I think it was or around yeah
$140 and the question is is the wick
failed now has the wick been failed my
answer is yes and I'm going to justify
it okay for me AWI has been filled once
it has filled at least 50% of it now
that's what we've done we've done in
fact even more because that
consolidation there that telling you you
know there's going to be one more Spike
to hit uh more of this area and it
pretty much filled the week at 90
something per okay because you can see
that the week has been a price
difference of
4% okay and we failed
exactly 3. 74% okay so pretty much
pretty much everything so to me yes the
Weck has been filled now we're going to
talk based on liquidations based Bas on
liquidity based on what the order book
says based on what high Capital says if
there is a reason for the market maker
to still push price higher to exactly
49k okay and that would be exactly the
100% of the week right but you have to
be able to make that difference there is
no reason in terms of the week fill
strategy to push price higher to the
100% of the week because we've already
retraced at least 90% of it right so
there is no any reason in fact if if
from here we saw this rejection at the
50% of the week and we retraced there
wouldn't have been any justification to
hope for price to reach this area
between 48 and 49k the only thing that
was telling us the idea that that was
going to happen and we were going to
retrace more of this week was this
consolidation around the 50% of the week
all right that was the only signal that
was telling us yes we can retrace more
of this week but as of now with a % plus
fill it doesn't need to get for that for
that extra 10% okay the wick has been
filled I want you guys to have that
clear but again we're want to go through
h capital the order book we want to see
if there is still some liquidations up
there and if there is then yes you can
justify that move to 49k still all right
that's very important now let's look at
the structure please pay attention how
the 50% of the week has been the new
support check that out look at all those
scandles there testing as support all
right it's quite interesting but that
happens quite a lot and that's again
what is telling you yes is support there
is going to be a bit more of
continuation okay aiming for uh to fill
more of this week now the thing is that
we've lost that support and this scandle
of course it hasn't closed yet it still
has a couple of hours um it close during
the New York session it's closing below
it and it's test our resistance which is
a bad sign okay so the 4 hours time
frame is true that it doesn't look that
good now if you go into the 1 hour time
frame we're going to see how we is still
holding one important support and that's
the 50 EMA check that out this purple
line okay we've been tested our support
once 2 three four five times so for now
we can say that we shouldn't expect
lower prices as long as we are holding
above the 50 MAA if we lose it
consolidate below it or even test it at
resistance then yes that'll be your
short signal okay that's important in
the 15 minutes time frame the chart is
also not looking that bad why well
because we created this week over here
okay you guys can see that if we Mark
that week you can see how we did a sweep
of the lows then we tested a support so
so far it's looking good you know you
can do something like this still and go
higher so the one time frame is not
looking bad the 15 minutes time frame is
not looking at it's not looking bad
sorry the 4 hours time frame he is still
is not looking too bad because it hasn't
closed the scandle but uh this is the
only cause of concern in the chart to me
is the 4our time frame I don't like that
we've lost that support and that we are
possibly testing our resistance in the
next candles all right so pay attention
to it so for now link it a bit to the
one time frame 50 MAA lose the 50 Ma in
the one time frame then the chart might
take a little drop all right and of
course altcoins are going to follow
because if we check the Bitcoin
dominance we can see how the Bitcoin
dominance keeps going up if any Bitcoin
has I want you to check this out okay go
to bitcoin first okay so bit the top of
Bitcoin was um basically midnight on
Monday and then it dropped okay and it
dropped
uh 2% now go to the Bitcoin
dominance
Monday let me see Monday at 12 so that's
around here okay that's around here this
candle here we are literally the same
level we only drop a 0.08% so we are
literally the same level okay that is
telling you that Al alins should be
taken a little drop go to salana look at
that drop but haven't checked this chart
okay I'm just improvising poot
dropping um I don't know XP is quite
stable Co lately but still dropping I
don't know Matic is probably dropping
let me check Matic Matic dropping quite
a lot okay so if we
lose the 1 hour 50 main but for now what
I would like to see is first of all Alin
recovering a tiny bit like this okay
towards that level recovered a bit and
then if at the same time the timing is
perfect and we lose the 1 hour 50 ma in
Bitcoin I'm not short in Bitcoin I'm
short in altcoins because the Bitcoin
dominance is not dropping with Bitcoin
okay and that's why altcoins are taking
a bigger dump so um I mean that's
basically in terms of efficiency you can
of course if that happens
um short Bitcoin but you're going to
have a bigger reward in altcoins uh at
least right now okay the same as for
during the weekend atum Friday you know
if Bitcoin consolidates around here then
altcoins are going to are going to pump
a lot and they did basically because
Bitcoin when Bitcoin pumps like this
crazy the Bitcoin dominance is going to
do the same okay it pumps crazy too and
altcoins are not going to be able to
pump that hard but once over the weekend
Bitcoin consolidates that's when
altcoins can explode let's go to chain
Ling guys uh um for example this chart I
don't know look at this this was on
Saturday okay look at this basically
Monday to Friday not move there was some
upside some onside but at the end you
know if you check Monday at 1 in the
morning and you checked H Friday at
midnight basically it's the same level
it didn't move but then Bitcoin
Consolidated over the weekend and that's
when alquin can go up look at that okay
so that's you have to also understand
this cycle between Bitcoin altcoins and
the Bitcoin dominance because that's
going to be able to offer you some
trading opportunities over the weekend
with altcoins and then if you have to
short well maybe you can sometimes
choose altcoins over Bitcoin okay so um
I mean I could make a whole video just
about this let me know if that's a good
idea but the Bitcoin dominance is a very
useful uh tool that I like now I would
like to stop talking and go to High
capital and there book let's check out
the liquidity guys and let's try to make
some sense of it this is high Capital
guys let's start with the liquidation
levels we we used to start always with
the liquidation levels okay the first
thing I I mentioned this on yester this
Bitcoin soon the update the first thing
that worries me a bit is all of these
long liquidations at 23 billion okay of
course take these numbers with a pin of
Sal cuz it's not a real number okay but
based on history based on my experience
with this liquidation level chart when
the liquidation levels get when the
Delta gets between 20 and $0
billion that is when it's selling you be
careful because there might be a reverse
in the chart okay there might be a
shorter squeeze or in this case that we
have all Market positions in Longs there
are lot of late long positions people
that open long positions quite late and
there is a lot of formal kicking in so
there might be a a long squeeze okay
that's the opposite of a short squeeze
long squeeze is when everybody's long
and then the market needs to do a flush
to the downside to to stop a lot of
positions and reset the Delta okay so be
careful with that because $23 billion
worth of long liquidations is quite a
lot for for high low Capital all right
now uh you can see some spikes at the
right of the chart I can see already a
spike here let me see that one there
46,500 big spike there to the down side
we also have another one here at 45,600
and to the upside I see also a few of
course it's a bit less than to the
downside but still there are a couple
levels that are very interesting check
this out
48,500 that's quite interesting level
and you also have here
qu a lot less okay but
49,0 29 that seems to be the most
interesting level okay so keep an eye on
that 49,000 based on the liquidation
levels is still would make sense to push
price up to 49,000 take all these
remaining liquidations to the upside the
short liquidations and then drop reset
the Delta back to zero and that would
mean that Bitcoin would have to drop all
the way to 46
45k all right so quite an interesting
chart
is basically giv you a warning of a long
squeeze but also a bit of hope that
Bitcoin could go to 49k First still okay
before reversing so be careful with your
leverage keep an eye on your stop loss
keep an eye on the chart if you don't
have much screen time because things
might change quickly okay now let's go
to the liquidation hit map 7 Days time
frame and yesterday we saw some
liquidations at
49,000 they haven't taken them yet with
that Spike that pack didn't get there it
got to
48850 the liquidations are at 48,900 so
they missed by I look at the chart
earlier and I think they missed by
something like4 $40 difference but what
they think what they've done with this
move by avoiding this uh liquidation
area is to increase the liquidity there
because there are obviously now some
people going
short and those liquidations are
stucking at this area so guys in the
heat map we have 48,900 and in the
liquidation levels we have 49,000 so
keep that in mind okay 48,900 and 49,000
there is a chance that we push price
back up to that area take all those
liquidations and then the final flish
down or we just might drop from here
that's that's the that's the good thing
of the of the chart that we don't know
what's going to happen first but it
would make sense to be honest to go to
49k still and then drop so uh keep an
eye on on that scenario I don't see
Bitcoin uh I don't know how to say this
okay Bitcoin could go high of course um
and and on Friday's video I think it was
we saw in in high time frame that there
was a resistance of
52,000 and then the next resistance is
60k so if we go about 52k then we're
going to we're going to be pretty fast
at 60k because there is not much
resistance on the way but good bit can
go to 52k in the short
term um it could but I think it's more
likely that we have a longest squeeze
first okay that means that maybe we have
the longest squeeze now and we drop to
46k 45k or we go to first to 49k and
then we have the longest squeeze but I
personally see less likely that we go
from here to 52k straight away I don't
know if that was clear I hope yes uh but
again it's based on my analysis and also
intuition now I want to go to the other
book to see if it says the same this is
the other book guys I'm sure that most
of you are now familiar with this uh for
those that don't know the order books
try to understand it as a book of orders
okay a book of orders of all the traders
that are trading in an exchange okay
this order book takes uh binance by bit
takes different exchanges okay um takes
all the orders that the retail Traders
are placing all right Al not also retail
Traders but also market makers and
that's the trick that maybe you see a
poofing well spoofing is quite complex
concept but it's basically a trick in
the order book maybe you see that there
is a cell wall and suddenly when we are
about to hit it it disappears okay so
you have to be careful with that but the
order book it shows orders those orders
are limit orders the limit orders can be
buy and sell orders can be liquidations
can be stop losses can be take profits
so it's kind of mixed up all in there
and it's difficult to know which is
which but we have the external tool of
high block Capital that only tells us
about the liquidations and what did it
say guys 49,000 and 48,900 look at the
other book you see where the liquidity
is basically we have three red bars
that's basically what the most liquidity
is is is is at the moment and that is
between
49,000 and 48,900 and for well I'm
48,800 so in that area that we have so
much
liquidity we could confirm that those
are going to be liquidations so uh also
if you look at the order book and you
look to the downside because the current
price is at 48,000 if you look down in
this in this chart
you don't really see many orders to the
downside do you okay because they are
below they are basically below
46,500 and around 45k that are also some
long liquidations okay and those are
going to be the target of a potential
long squeeze all the way there so yes I
mean we could say that the order book is
showing a lot of liquidity at 49,000 and
48,00 in between that area of
$200 and in that same area we can see a
lot Liquidations in h capital so they
are matching we having the same
information those are liquidations okay
so yes there is a reason for the market
maker that's a justification for them to
push price higher to hit all those
liquidations because when somebody gets
liquidated all that money goes to the
exchange okay and the exchange pays the
market maker so it's a business guys it
makes sense to attack those liquidations
okay so I hope that was clear these 3
minutes explanation about the other book
we're want to go back now to the Bitcoin
chart so this is pretty simple guys we
can say that where the 100% of the week
is in that area between
49,000 and
48,800 that's there is a lot of
liquidity up there there is a lot of
liquidations so price could go there and
from there I would say it's likely that
we see a rejection okay of course I want
to pay attention to what happens in the
moment but uh
it makes sense for a long squeeze and I
I have the feeling that it should happen
a long squeeze but if we get first to
49,000 that's the area where I'm going
to be looking for shorts okay uh how I'm
going to trade this well basically in
the 1 hour time frame what I'm going to
do is I'm going to open a small long
position at the 50 MAA targeting 49
between 49,0
48,800 so that $200 a region
okay with a small size okay then once in
the 4H hour time frame if we see a
candle closing back below this yellow
line that's the 50% of the week 48,000
because you can see that right now we
are testing our resistance so if we
close it above it or the next one we
close above it okay then that's when I'm
going to add size to my position that's
called compound okay that's when I add
size to my lungs because I have more
conviction that it's going to play out
if however this is my validation if we
drop below the 1 hour 50 Ma and we start
to do some consolidation below it or we
tested a resistance for two or three
candles that is basically when I'm
switching to a short position in
altcoins okay of course I have to first
check the altcoins for example
Matic it would be a good one to short if
at the right time well first needs to
recover here but then if once it's at
the 1 hour 50 ma then Bitcoin loses it's
1 hour 15ma and we are testing below it
then for example that is when I'm short
in Matic okay and I can tell you Matic
but I can also tell you for example
paulot or I don't know if you notice
what the chart is doing is basically
lower highs okay and also lower lows all
right so it's in a it's right now in a
downtrend
so if it recovers this for example this
liquidity pool over here that's a
liquidity pool this candle here that's
going to be pretty much at the same time
as the 1 50 is going to retrace to this
level so we test this level 1 50 may
this liquidity pool then at the same
time Bitcoin loses is 50 Ma we're
consolidating below it or testing our
resistance then that's what I'm
basically switching to a short in padot
in Matic targeting new Lo lows okay uh I
want that to be quite simple I think
it's uh e to understand or at least I
hope that so yep keep an eye on 49,000
but also please keep an eye on that
longest qu scenario okay if we go to
49,000 of course I'm going to update
again if it happens in 24 hours you'll
have a new video tomorrow at the same
time or if it happens today then I post
an update on telegram or on X thank you
very much for watching in the videos and
I'll see you soon